Message à l'intention des abonnés : à la fin de la vidéo, j'ai un petit message pour vous.
Salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi c'est donc le jour de l'astuce du mercredi.
Cette semaine dans les commentaires vous avez été deux à me poser une question
très très pertinente concernant les sectes qui recrutaient à la sortie des lycées, des universités, des lieux où on peut trouver des jeunes....
et donc vous m'avez demandé d'en parler.
Ok vous n'étiez que 2 mais j'ai trouvé le sujet assez pertinent
pour qu'on en parle aujourd'hui dans l'astuce du mercredi. C'est vrai que certains regroupements, certaines sectes
ont une approche très moderne dans leurs recrutements aujourd'hui en 2016.
Ça passe par les mails, par les DVD, par de l'achat de mots clés sur internet,
par du contenu un peu publirédactionnel
sur lequel on peut tomber quand on tape une recherche sur google par exemple.
C'est très très bien déguisé, c'est très bien orchestré,
et surtout ça utilise tous les codes de la communication d'aujourd'hui.
Ils savent que nous, les jeunes,
le premier qui rit du fait que je me place dans les jeunes, je lui envoie Sylvain Durif et un vaisseau,
Ils savent que les jeunes sont sensibles à tout l'univers de la communication.
On est habitué à voir des publicités partout
on est habitué à ces codes là de communication
et ils rentrent complètement dans la brèche.
De la même manière ils vont investir des lieux en déguisant un petit peu l'objet du lieu.
Par exemple l'église de scientologie a beaucoup de librairies,
de librairies sur le développement personnel, sur le bien-être.
Et quand on rentre dans ces librairies là, on trouve que des livres de la scientologie
et des gentils libraires qui vous accueillent et essayent de vous endoctriner ni plus ni moins.
Leur but n'est pas de vous aider.
L'auto-financement, ça va être en vous vendant des livres,
des DVD, des conférences à 500 €, et parfois même sans rien vous vendre.
Mais en utilisant votre temps et votre engagement.
Je croyais que le plus dangereux, c'était le recrutement qu'ils font souvent à la sortie des lycées.
Et bizarrement c'est beaucoup moins efficace pour eux que de faire ça auprès des étudiants sur les campus.
Je pense que c'est parce que quand on est au lycée , on est en plein développement de l'esprit critique,
et c'est le moment où on remet en question pas mal de vérités.
D'ailleurs ils ne tractent pas, ils sont plus malins que ça, ils font remplir un questionnaire.
Un questionnaire de 200 questions je crois,
qui va de "est ce que vous mastiquez lentement ou rapidement ?"
à "que pensez-vous de Dieu et de la spiritualité ?"
Ça c'est une technique de manipulation
parce qu'ils sont extrêmement doués là-dedans.
On en avait d'ailleurs parlé dans la vidéo sur les manipulateurs.
C'est le principe du "je commence par dire oui, oui, oui, oui et je continue de dire oui".
Evidemment il y a des remparts à ça et c'est la question de l'astuce du jour.
Ces deux remparts sont la culture et l'esprit critique.
Mais la vraie astuce de cette vidéo, et c'est en ça que vous m'avez posé par deux fois la question cette semaine,
c'est comment driver quelqu'un qui s'est déjà fait endoctriner.
Alors je parle de l'église de la scientologie parce que pour moi, ce sont les plus efficaces en terme de manipulation.
Premièrement, ne soyez pas critique envers cet ami.
Ça pourrait avoir l'effet inverse.
Le fait de critiquer ouvertement la communauté qu'il est en train de rejoindre,
ça va simplement le braquer, parce qu'il n'est pas prêt à ça, en fait.
Lui, il est dans une autre vérité, il est dans une autre réalité, et vous allez complètement le faire fuir.
Ça va être pire, parce qu'il va avoir l'impression de n'être compris que par ces vrais amis
et sa vraie famille qui sont les autres.
Soyez le plus présent possible, le plus aimant possible.
Ne cherchez pas à le mettre sur la défensive, et au contraire, écoutez le parler de ça.
Ecoutez le vous vendre le produit. Ne vous faîtes pas avoir, gardez votre esprit critique.
Mais laissez le parler, laissez-le raconter tout ce qu'il a à vous raconter.
Laissez le aller loin dans son propre argumentaire.
En fait il est en train de lui-même continuer de se convaincre
et le fait de le verbaliser, ça peut le mettre face à face
envers des choses qui sont étranges en fait,
sur lesquelles lui-même a du mal à admettre.
Et au milieu de ça, faites en sorte vraiment de le stimuler dans un vrai environnement sain,
festif si vous avez une relation festive, familial si vous avez une relation familiale.
Faîtes lui faire des activités, offrez lui un cadre de vie complet.
Le but c'est que comme ça, il puisse prendre conscience lui même des propres incohérences.
C'est le meilleur chemin. Si par exemple, en vous parlant de tout ça, il vous dit :
"En plus c'est bien pour moi parce que j'avais pas beaucoup d'amis, les gens ils pensent pas à moi" etc ...,
alors organisez une soirée entres amis, faites en sorte que ses amis pensent à lui et lui fassent voir.
Que lui même puisse se rendre compte que non,
sa réalité, ce n'est pas celle qu'on est en train de lui expliquer.
Et enfin quand vous aurez complètement sa confiance, que vous aurez fait des choses ensemble,
qu'il se sera déjà longuement exprimé sur le sujet, forcez le à développer un argumentaire.
Mettez en avant ce qui vous paraît étrange comme si vous ne l'aviez pas compris
et faîtes en sorte que lui puisse formuler cette réponse.
Il y a de fortes chances que, même s'il ne verbalise pas ce que vous voulez,
votre question fasse quand même son petit bout de chemin dans sa tête.
Sachez également que dans les cas les plus graves, il y a des consultants qui existent par rapport à ça.
Ils sont capables de déprogrammer dans le temps quelqu'un qui a été vraiment manipulé.
Je sais que même aux Etats-Unis il y a des consultants qui kidnappent la personne
pour une déprogrammation de force.
Evidemment, je ne recommande pas ça du tout.
Mais il existe quand même des thérapeutes
qui font ce consulting là d'une manière plus douce et surtout pour qu'elle tienne dans le temps
puisque pour les personnes les plus fragiles, l'implantation est vraiment grave.
Je vous mets quelques liens dans le descriptif vers des sites internet et des bouquins.
Si jamais vous avez besoin d'aller plus loin là dessus, n'hésitez pas.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. N'hésitez pas à la partager.
Je pense que celle-ci est plus importante que les autres.
En faisant des recherches sur le sujet, je me suis rendu compte à quel point
ces sectes là sont organisées et surtout, je le répète, sont vraiment très modernes dans leur approche.
C'est du business hyper bien pensé. C'est un bon mélange de manipulation et de communication.
Donc il faut être très critique vis à vis de tout ça, bien comprendre les choses et surtout avoir connaissance de ça.
Après évidemment, je vous rassure, la team Mentalo n'est pas une secte
donc vous pouvez , pour la fin de cette vidéo, laissez un petit "POUCE EN L'AIR"
Ça, ça coûte rien, y a pas de danger. Vous pouvez également laisser un petit commentaire.
Je les lis et j'y réponds ... en ce moment une fois par semaine mais j'y réponds toujours.
Le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc abonnez-vous à la chaîne et rendez-vous demain à 17h. Ciao !
Vous savez, de temps en temps, j'aime bien faire une vidéo avec vous.
Aujourd'hui, sur la fanpage du Facebook dont vous avez le lien dans le descriptif,
je vous ai posé une question pour la vidéo de demain suite à la vidéo que j'avais fait hier avec Philippe Roche.
Qui est ce que vous voulez que j'essaie d'imiter en appliquant les conseils que m'a donné Philippe ?
Voilà, je veux faire une vidéo là-dessus. Répondez moi sur la fanpage de Facebook.
Ça me permet de centraliser toutes les réponses au même endroit.
Faites le évidemment avant demain midi que je puisse tourner la vidéo. Ciao !